denise joining us now is mary
blankenship she is a researcher at
unlv's brookings mountain west
specializing in social media
misinformation also a native of ukraine
and mary thank you so much for joining
us thank you for having me you've been
analyzing social media what are you
seeing in terms of the war in the
invasion of ukraine in terms of
misinformation and disinformation
well the majority of the tweets for
example and the posts online are
standing in support and solidarity of
ukraine quite a lot of it is
propaganda disinformation misinformation
meant to
show
the motivation of the russian aggression
but also intimidate the ukrainian troops
and people into submission into russia
how can people tell the difference in
terms of the legitimacy of what they're
seeing well that can be very difficult
and so
one of the things that is possible to do
is a check
for the original source right
go to the original source as much as
possible
and then also look for local sources as
well they have the tendency to show the
most accurate and up-to-date data
on what what is going on with the
conflicts mary you make such a good
point there because you're talking about
even today news outlets in russia shut
down facebook and twitter shut down so
the need for real authentic information
in this war is so essential isn't it yes
one of the big components of this war is
the information warfare that is going on
and that is a strong suit of russia but
we're noticing within this conflict that
a lot of
media especially foreign media and
western media is catching up so they're
really struggling to pass on their
messages if i could pivot topics a bit
you are from ukraine you have seen your
people and their fight we've all seen it
these are very hearty courageous brave
people talk a little bit about the men
and women that have just amazed the
world in the past couple of weeks with
their resilience i'm so happy that
people are finally starting to see just
how amazing ukrainians are and i've
never been prouder to be ukrainian
it's it's really painful to watch
as as a ukrainian
abroad and i think for also a lot of
ukrainian americans to see
so many people in my country struggle
needlessly and again when we look into
this we look at putin's despotic views
this is really just about ukraine
wanting to be free and independent and
considering nato and considering ideals
of the west it's really just about a
country wanting to do what they want to
do oh yes and putin uses these excuse
to
validate his aggression but if you pay
attention to the language that he uses
in his speeches and in the articles that
he publishes it's really about
reforming the soviet union it's pure a
power grab and nothing else which makes
it so much more evil last question what
can our viewers that are watching and
they want to help but they want to make
sure it's a legitimate source to help
what can we do where can we find ways to
help
there are many ways viewers can help
first and foremost is to show your
solidarity with ukraine the biggest
thing that is keeping
ukraine from
from surrendering is the sheer weir
is the sheer will and determination of
the people
so they need to know that the world is
behind him but then of course there are
more practical ways to help including
donating for military and medical
supplies
for example there is first friday
tonight that is selling
art and proceeds that will be donated to
different charities you can also there's
a rally tomorrow at city hall that
people can go to to show their support
and
go outreach their local governments mary
thank you so much i know you have family
and friends in central ukraine as well
as odessa we are thinking about all the
people of ukraine we thank you so much
for being here and spending some time
and lending your expertise we're going
to send it back over now to denise